are you guys are dressed to play you
look good you got your your team swag on
I like it I like it did you help in you
know coming up with a design on this or
is it something that they just did for
you and say here you're wearing this
Phil did you have anything to say about
what you're wearing no no but you know
not well I didn't and what you have on
well I have to be very particular
because when you carry a few extra
pounds as I do yeah you have to dress
appropriately so I wear a lot of black
oh that's why it's just very slimming
exactly you see me in bright colors and
like you can wear anything well you know
what I'm getting older and I'm starting
to put on a little bit of weight here
that baby fat it came off but now it's
time to come back as adult fat so I I am
actually you know I wear my stuff
tighter so a lot of the boys on my team
and even the American side always give
me a bit of stick with hair tight I wear
my stuff but you you shall show off the
arms though Phil right you normally do
that I have like two features that I
showed off his legs he has some good
cars
really oh okay so the poll question is
what did we ask about caddying best kind
of backup job in sports would you rather
be the caddy for the best golfer in the
world for a decade or the backup
quarterback for the best quarterback in
the world for thinking so like you know
Stevie Williams right Tigers run or
Peyton Manning had Jim Sergey behind him
who rarely played but you got a backup
Peyton Manning for 10 years which job
would you want I'd take the caddy job
you just never know when the guys gonna
get injured in football and then you're
on the spot you like I actually got to
show my talent now way better be good
Jason you get in the game yeah well yeah
yeah Phil what about you well I would
think the backup quarterback you if
something we're happy you'd actually
have a chance to play yeah I'd want to
be that so instead of if Tiger gets
heard Stevie doesn't get to play no yeah
I've got a couple of weeks extra at home
I think I mean you still probably get
most likely yeah plus backup
quarterbacks get paid what starters used
to ten fifteen years ago but Stevie got
paid well yes because Tiger makes on the
course is nowhere near what what the
backup quarters are making now could you
find out I think it's a lot safer to if
you if you're looking at just straight
money I think it's a lot safer big Cody
did you ever have an embarrassing moment
though with your caddy I mentioned
before you guys came in I caddy for
Peter Jacobson at the par-3 at Augusta
okay and all the clubs spilled out
because he had the yeah he had the
double and yeah that's a complete rookie
move
well I and then I started leaning and
all the clubs are like you can just hear
him just hit the ground I barely
survived the nine holes there yeah
because he wanted to fire the crazy
thing is you know you didn't take the
whole set did you or did you yeah but
you took the driver and everything yeah
he's the one it made me do it yeah he
set me up
and then we're playing with Payne
Stewart and Fred Couples and you know
how pain could be yeah he was giving me
grief the whole time and then finally he
gave me a club on the night that he goes
here go ahead swing you think it's easy
I hear you guys on TV oh yeah no I
didn't do it but I got to the green they
said here and he gave me his putter and
told me to putt I'm you know like my
hands are like this it's packed there
people think you know what you're doing
I had no idea what I'm doing
so Payne passed away in 99 unfortunately
and but maybe we should come up with
some new material Dan that I should how
many wins you've had right
oh yeah okay oh the wells a little dry
right now for both of us
Phil Mickelson and Jason Day Joe
where do you want to go here do you ever
does this ever get competitive though
with you guys I know it's it it has the
feeling it's not right or Cup
competition but it's pretty close with
that but does it ever get personal with
anybody when you guys play in these
events no I think these guys are really
good at gaming gaming you know their
competition I think I mean I I
definitely say you know these guys have
had had us down numbers for though since
98 really I mean that was the only time
we once when I had to do material yeah
exactly and when you have the new
material mates so um yeah it is it's
gonna be tough this week but saying that
I think we've got a good team to beat
try me these guys do you ever make it
personal well here's the thing Jason and
Adam Scott - which are probably I didn't
mean - because they're the nicest these
two are the nicest guys you could ever
imagine is it and so off the outside of
this one week you can't help but love
and like being around them and respect
them so you don't want one week to take
away from that and so but that's the
same is match-play I mean when we play
match play or I don't give I usually
don't give a putz and people get angry
at me for it but I mean it's just
there's no hard feelings you know what I
mean yeah they try them do a job and win
and that's the same thing is I think
that's what's so great about this
generation when you look at the young
guys though is that they love to compete
play against each other and yet they're
supportive for each other's success yeah
and I think that it's kind of started
with Jason's generation Jason I think
it's 29 now kind of started with that
time frame you look at guys like jordan
Spieth and and Justin Thomas who compete
and and love playing against each other
but then they're supportive of each
other which is a really cool thing
that's going on in the sports right now
how'd you guys react I don't know if you
have time to talk to others but what
happened with the NFL this weekend with
the the protest and I know you'd be in
an all-around sports fan you two as well
James but is
is something that is conversation that
has come up will come up I think it's
always gonna come up every Sunday you
know III think you know that's just a
tough one for us cuz I mean obviously
you know we only become a team you know
for these guys they have a team sport
every single year mm-hmm for us it's
every couple years and we got enough on
our plates right now to try and beat
these guys cuz we haven't won in 20
years or so so that makes it tough for
us but I think I think field probably
has a better answer than I do what was
your reaction well there are social
injustice does that continue in this
country we should all strive to to
eliminate that but for this this week I
am so proud to represent my country to
I'm so appreciative of all the
opportunities this great country has
given me I get to play golf for a living
there's just no greater thing in the
that I could ever imagine and I get to
do what I love and I'm just so
appreciative of the many opportunities
countries giving me but we should all
strive to eliminate social injustice
that continue no certainly we've made a
lot of strides over the years but we can
always get better
are you a Cleveland Browns fan Jason you
know what the other week I was actually
this is this is how sad it is I was
actually angry at my TV because they
didn't sell out and it wasn't on TV they
were playing the steel is and I'm
sitting there like a cow gonna watch the
Browns I might be sad at the end of the
day but saying that and then I turned
the TV on it I was already sad because I
can watch it because they didn't sell
that so they would they blocked it and
no matter where I couldn't even phonce
it it actually ended up being I okay
you've got to get DIRECTV I didn't have
DirecTV but they didn't they didn't
allow it because they didn't sell out so
they did they blocked it already channel
that he can get excited to watch the
Browns team are you following them in
Los Angeles
yeah but I'm not as passionate as I was
but I still follow I'm sure I'm more of
a a Cavs fan that the headset they feels
got in front of him yeah have you met
LeBron you know I just know I haven't
like I didn't when I go there so when
the the day that he ran over my wife
you didn't say lower a weird thing that
happened but anyways I'll explain it so
people understand that he didn't like
run her over outside of the around what
happened what happened is that I have my
buddy though in the state he's sitting
there and I'm talking to him my wife
Ellie and his wife Kelly are sitting
there talking and then I'm sitting here
talking to Andy looking this way
and then I kind of look I'm looking down
I see this ball going like this and then
all of a sudden all you see is his
265-pound dude come out and literally no
it was like a leg it happened so fast
I'm not expecting it you're just sitting
there looking at this ball and then he
runs in you're like all of a sudden the
only thing that I could do was that
thing it was literally the worst thing
that I could probably do as a husband
and not try and do this you know what I
mean but I just had no idea what was
going on I'm like whoa and then he ran
Ellie over if I gave you a mulligan
you've done it probably I probably would
have tested him back onto the court
[Laughter]
crushed I would have just kind of balled
up so I don't have my I can hurt in golf
man it's a non-contact sport so I
probably would have most likely even if
he brushed me up our way to go ahead
have you ever had you sit courtside you
had that you've never had that moment if
I said you could finish second or last
yeah a second to lost in what golf okay
you can finish second or you can finish
last what hurts more well being being
lost no one sees I mean second I much
rather finish second and fail at being
you know at not winning and being in the
spotlight because I know that it's just
around the corner you know what I mean
to a certain degree like when you're
last
yeah no one no you don't even on TV no
one sees you you know what I mean but
I'd much rather fell in front of a lot
of people and know that I've given it a
good shot then be like last did not be
on TV or or fellow that you're what
would you say feel well I think Ricky
Bobby said it best
so explain to me the love affair with
putters or the hatred with putters like
trying to find my putter you love your
hell I just changed
well I why'd you change well so I what
the biggest thing that happened was back
in 2011 I started using a spotter putter
it was white then I changed to black and
that I changed it red and then this hole
then the spotter putter was like the
number one putter on tour for I don't
even know if it is or if it still is but
it was it was huge
everyone started changing it because of
my season that I had in 2015 and 2016
and then Odyssey went and changed their
color to red and it like so that what
the actual story was is I was sitting
there with Col Mike oh oh caddy and a
guy from TaylorMade and I said you know
we want to put like a little bit of mr.
own flavor on it so we'll call it the
red back spider paint it red and call
the red backs water but then it comes
like once again I started putting
terrible this year so I changed to add
more to and has given me a little bit of
life again so saying that I I love my
putter what about you I'm waiting for
something smart to come out of milk I
don't know it's not coming to me right
now I do have a love affair or hatred I
have two or three putters that I like
that that feel good when you grow up
putting you develop a stroke that's
that's about around your putter so the
the way the face rotates the way you you
tend to gravitate towards butters like
that so I grew up with a blade a heel
shafted putter and when the shaft gets
more towards the center there's not as
much rotation I don't putt well so I
have to have a heel shafted putter
there's two or three that I really like
and I continue to go back and forth
between them but I've been on the same
putter now well since the last time I
won so quite some time but have you ever
broken a putter snap oh yeah yeah yeah
definitely I do it I'd feel no no come
on Phil you know I never broke a club
you never because when I was a kid I
used to have to pay for my club and I've
never broken a club as a kid a bargain a
club is professional yes when we get
them for free that's why I did it yeah
will there be any side bets that
with this residents come you know I
don't have dinner on writing something
or it's frowned upon it is anyone who's
gonna bet it's this guy yeah yeah we're
it's never happened yeah never nothing
even Ryder Cup no you chase nah mate
Phil's a good actor right here if it
feels like you might have something I
like money I like I like I like making
money I don't like giving otherwise
that's what I bet what's the most you
ever seen bet on a golf course
well I was I was down at the place
called capital in Australia and a lot of
the Chinese come down and gamble at the
Crown Casino and these guys usually when
you go and play the capital it's a
private of course and a lot of these
guys bet you know hundred to two hundred
thousand dollars a whole whoo
yes so they they're pretty pretty heavy
hitters but you're not betting that of
course not I'm not even in their same
league I'm not even I'm actually I just
see them walking across the putting
range touch the ball probably where you
have to play it where it lies you know
how to put your hands on it I get I get
angry if at least 20 bucks I don't even
bother come in for me for a bit
he's Phil Mickelson and he's Jason Day
Presidents Cup coming up on Thursday at
Liberty national and goes through Sunday
October 1st you'll have the golf channel
on NBC with coverage of that Presidents
Cup featuring Team USA team
international which is comprised of the
world's best players outside of Europe
tune in to see Phil's big arms and and
an outfit that I don't think he's too
thrilled to wear is that fair to say no
I love wearing me just so it could be
black that would be even better
yes stripes don't do it for me really
don't all right thank you for coming in
it's great to see you guys Jason Day I
feel Nicholson the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience